hallo wir sind gerade unterwegs und zwar
sind wir in colorado im garten auf ich
fühle mich gerne einmal ganz oben drehen
aber das steht dass ein umgehen gucke
ich das mal hier an wir sind hier mitten
in der landschaft ist das nicht ein
komisches spiel gitarre hallo januar
bekommen eher hoch spielhaus für uns und
heißt ben und easy und wir beantworten
jetzt eure fragen bei kari antwortet
unterwegs nummer 35
wieso hast du eine frage für uns ist ein
mikrofon
los gehts gestellt von french wenn wir
kommen in den usa ich hoffe dass sie
alle spaß während der reise macht danke
friends fällen danke dass du uns viel
spaß wünscht dass seine antwort auf die
letzte episode auf dem rockefeller
center in new york und diese diesen
kommentar wollen wir nehmen um euch
einen tipp zu geben das ist mir
aufgefallen vor allem amerikaner und
englischlehrer speaker sagen ganz oft
macht viel spaß gemacht was hat er noch
geschrieben macht viel spaß
genau und da müsst ihr wissen es gibt im
deutschen zwei redewendungen oder zwei
teams sozusagen mit spaß einmal spaß
haben to have fun also genau wie im
englischen und einmal es macht mir spaß
also da ist quasi die person die spaß
hat das objekt und das müsst ihr wissen
und euch immer daran erinnern wenn ihr
eine eine auswählt entweder entweder
sagte es macht mir spaß
oder ich hoffe es macht spaß
oder habt viel spaß also wenn die person
die spaß hat das subjekt sein soll müsst
ihr immer einfach wie im englischen
sagen to have fun bei harry potter fan
ich hoffe ihr habt viel spaß und
verwechselt das nicht wenn ihr das mit
dem macht machen benutzt dann müsst ihr
immer ein ass und ein
da tief dazu haben nämlich es macht mir
spaß es macht ihr spaß es macht euch
spaß wie sie haben wir noch eine frage
erklärt karin zweite frage von tobias
dieser episode kann man gut für einen
trinkspiel nutzen jedes mal wenn kari
scheiß oder scheiße sagt wird getrunken
hh smiley ja danke tobias tatsächlich
nicht die letzte mal verleiten lassen
ein paar viele schimpfwörter zu benutzen
sogar isi hat komisch geguckt als ich so
viele schimpfwörter gesagt habe scheiße
scheiße scheiße kari das hättest du
nicht tun sollen
dafür möchte ich ihnen entschuldigen
ehrlich gesagt hatten wir ein bisschen
panik zwischendurch am nächsten morgen
ich und das video veröffentlicht dachte
ich scheiße das video hat viel zu viele
schimpfwörter
ich dachte oh mann das video hat vize
chef weiter
und dann habe ich aber dann habe ich
aber die ganze kapital gesehen und die
kontron total positiv die leute haben
gesagt ich hätte so ehrlich geantwortet
und es wäre so straight forward und so
das fand ich ganz geil danke für eure
ganzen netten kommentare
die waren sehr ermutigend letzte mal war
er ist das ein ausblick
sie ist das der hammer hammer mäßige aus
liegt ja nur spät kommt mal hoch
sie hat ein bisschen bewegen dass alle
nächste frage von paul king paul king
die frage die ich mir gestellt paul ist
bist du franzose und fragt ob wir dich
auch hassen oder bist du nicht franzoso
nichtdeutscher und fragt sich ob wir uns
gegenseitig hassen
also fand deutsche und franzosen hassen
sich nicht mehr
gott sei dank haben wir erstmalig lassen
wir uns nicht mehr es gab einen ganz
ganz ganz ganz lange zeit wo sich
deutsche und franzosen überhaupt nicht
gemocht haben es gab natürlich auch zwei
große kriege zwischen deutschland
frankreich aber das hat sich geändert
und wir hassen die franzosen nicht
wie sieht es bei euch aus ihr franzosen
hasst ihr uns oh jetzt kommt noch eine
frage ja
übrigens auf instagram folgen ben an der
score kamera macht wunderbare fotos
jeden tag von unserer tour so von
ressourcen ist klar jetzt frage ich dich
was denkst du ist der große unterschied
zwischen den deutschen und amerikaner
also das interessiert mich als
kolumbianer zu wissen weil ich werde
reise nach deutschland ist es ja und ich
würde gerne wissen was ist der
unterschied kultur zwischen euch und wir
ja ich möchte die frage beantworten oder
janisch wir hätten rede
das ist der große unterschied zwischen
deutschen und amerikanern janisch sap in
front diese frage ist mittlerweile schon
etliche male gestellt und beantwortet
worden
und ich denke dass das wichtigste ist
dass die amerikaner fiel auf einer viel
freundlicher viel neugieriger viel
mutiger sind viel sozialer sind
vergangen also also es gibt ganz viele
unterschiede und wir machen sogar
nächste woche ein video darüber deswegen
will ich nicht zu viel verraten
ein unterschied ist auch dass die
amerikaner sehr patriotisch sind und die
deutschen überhaupt nicht
hier im hintergrund seht ihr übrigens
die wunderschönen felsen das garden of
the guard und nächste frage ich sie von
georgia lake quebec kannst das nochmal
vor diesen fans
das ist nett wenn deine fans haben sich
gemeldet
was sagst du dazu wenden vielen dank das
ist ja ich stehe sehr selten vor der
kamera aber
freu mich danke wenn ihr auch ein band
fanseite und schreibt uns denn hätte
gerne mehr ferien kommentare und easy
auch ihr dürft uns alle persönlich
kommentare schreiben wir beantworten die
alle bei youtube alle oder wenn ihr
sollte auch unbedingt männer auf
instagram folgen ben an das score kamera
jeden tag gibt es tolle fotos aus den
usa dankeschön
was ist ein heutiges foto ben habe ich
noch nicht gemacht glaube ich kommt
nochmal eins von mir okay sie haben wir
noch langsam werde ich an meinen werden
danke maria für diesen kommentar ich
lass dir einfach unkommentiert ich finde
es toll dass uns geschrieben hast unsere
positive erfahrung gemacht hast auch
ostdeutschland hat ein schlechtes image
ganz oft in deutschland dass sie sehr
unfreundlich sind und vor allem auch
unfreundlich gegenüber ausländern sind
deswegen freut uns dein feedback und
danke dafür noch eine noch ein kommentar
philip roberts hat geschrieben
willkommen in new york city meiner
heimat startete ramon november age danke
für diesen tollen kommentar philipp
philipp ja wir haben ja schon mal etwas
gesagt über donald schon bei isar
germany diese episode war sehr populär
und auch sehr unpopulär in viele
transporter haben uns das damals übel
genommen dass wir uns politisch ein
bisschen positioniert haben wenn auch
nicht strahlt aber dazu 2 kommentare
erstens ich kann leider nicht bedauert
schon wählen denn ich bin kein
amerikaner und zweitens selbst wenn die
amerikaner wäre würde ich nicht für
donald trump wellen und der grund dafür
ist dass wir setzen uns ja mit dem was
wir machen aber auch mit dem was ich
außerhalb von easy german machen setze
ich mich dafür ein dass sich leute
verständigen dass sich kulturen
austauschen
das mehr freundschaften entstehen dass
vorurteile abgebaut werden das ist quasi
alles was ich in meinem leben mache und
das was donald trump sagt steht
eigentlich alles komplett konträr dazu
womit ich mein leben verbringen
deshalb würde ich nie nie nie nie nie
nie niemals donald trump wellen selbst
wenn ein weiß nicht wenn zu anderen wahl
ein pferd stehen würde
das ist ein tolles beispiel aber es ist
einfach ich denke nicht dass das was
sonnenschein gut ist ich denke dass er
sehr viel kaputt macht von dem was wir
eigentlich zusammen aufbauen sollten und
ich werde ja werden natürlich weiter
damit machen kulturaustausch und
vorurteile abbauen ist das wichtigste
auf der welt kann man ganz bestimmt
worte ausgekommen ist
bist du stolz das erste ganz toll
gemacht hast du noch einen kommentar
bratzel abo oder am razzia war hat
geschrieben
das heißt dass jan hartmann sah man das
internet kein märchen ist du musst dich
daran gewöhnen dass jede person
verschiedene meinung hat hässliche
ehrliche kommentare einschließlich um
genauer gesagt viele leute ganz
authentisch dass infos hier
du musst dich daran gewöhnen dass jede
person verschiedene meinungen hässlich
ehrliche kommentare einschließlich ich
am genauer gesagt viele leute denken
können persönlich daran dass da nach
einem furchtbaren akzent hat und dass
sie dass sie für eine deutsch sprachkurs
folge nicht geeignet ist ich sollte
darüber nicht schweigen ich habe keine
verantwortung um dann empfindliches
gefühl zu schützen
ich kann sagen irgendwas das ist bei der
meinungsfreiheit ja das war eine lange
diskussion auf youtube ich habe ihn
natürlich gelesen wenn auch nicht
persönlich stellung genommen
und natürlich wäre es wenn alba waka
waka waka waka waka bratze ich weiß
nicht ob du wirklich so heiß ich schätze
mal das ist ein synonym
natürlich kannst du deine meinung äußern
auf youtube natürlich darf so dass es
gibt natürlich meinungsfreiheit aber ist
es natürlich ein bisschen dämlich wenn
man ständig irgendwelche leute schlecht
macht und das dann als freie
meinungsäußerungen verkauft ich kann ja
auch jetzt sagen ich hasse easy weil sie
schwarze haare oder ich hasse ben weil
er aus england kommt
aber das mache ich nicht weil das ist
unfreundlich und das ist scheiße und
wenn du dir wenn du meinst dass das
leider meinungsäußerung gehört dann kann
ich auch genau sagen dass ich das nicht
gut finde es ist einfach unnütz also du
kannst ja das ist liegt ja in deiner
lebenseinstellung ob du den ganzen tag
damit verbringen über alles zu meckern
was du siehst oder ob du dich über das
freust was schönes gibt und wenn du
glaubst dass du auch den ganzen auf
youtube videos angucken musst du dir
eigentlich scheiße findet um dann scheiß
kommentar zu schreiben
dann tut mir das leid für dich guck doch
einfach ein anderes video oder oder
was sagt zählen dazu ich glaub selber
die diskussion aufgegeben gehabt ich
wollte zuschauer aufrufen und zwar haben
wir die frage bekommen mal ein video
darüber zu machen
tipps um nach deutschland zu ziehen ja
was muss ich beachten wenn man zb als
amerikaner aber vielleicht auch als
brasilianer nach deutschland ziehen
möchte als student oder zur arbeit
wir würden uns freuen wenn ihr uns mal
eure tipps schickt also persönlich eure
top 3 was war das wichtigste was ihr
beachten musste als ihr nach deutschland
gezogen seit und daraus machen wir dann
ein video das hoffentlich hilfreich ist
für viele leute die das noch machen
möchten und der zweite aufruf auf vor
wir das machen drehe ich mich noch mal
mein werk sein werden meine hände und
hast dass ein ausweg sie angst hast du
angst herunterzählt ich bin hier ständig
der flächen hinaus wickeln drück dir das
mal an wir sind hier mitten mehr hh
mitten in der geilsten szenerie der
letzte aufruf ist
wir sind jetzt in den usa nämlich viele
tolle leute getroffen schulklasse
universitäten
wir sind eingeladen worden von leuten
nach hause und wir möchten demnächst
auch gerne mal nach polen fahren deshalb
der anruf an alle polen leszek klima
polster
das war wahrscheinlich falsch aber wir
möchten nach polen fahren jan ich kann
das noch mal voll nicht sagen und wenn
ihr uns einladen möchte in eurer schule
in eure universität oder auch nach hause
einfach zum deutsch sprechen
dann schreibt uns unbedingt jetzt einen
kommentar der us politik wir möchten
dass leute uns einladen nach polen sagen
dieser branche
polski universität
dankeschön fürs zuschauen und bis zur
nächsten woche wir freuen uns auf eure
kommentare
stunde
die hand und wir